[Applause]
well good evening hi nice to be here
would you like to kick off I will kick
off
we've been scheming as you know we're
both here to talk about identity
politics if you know anything about our
work you know we're here to talk about
what's wrong with it we'll leave now yes
with in fact we theorized that these
tickets just cost just enough that our
detractors won't pay for a seat we're
gonna organize the evening in this
manner we talked a few minutes about the
general phenomenon what it is and why we
don't like it and then we thought we'd
follow the organizational structure of
Douglass's new book which is looking at
four categories of gays women race and
trends and then we're going to spend a
few minutes at the end wrapping up what
we both think we should do about this
what's the solution and that's going to
be the shortest part of the evening
because we really have no idea the rest
of the evening of course is going to be
up to you half an hour 35 minutes before
we go home it's it's up to you to come
up with some questions and something
about this subject matter suggests to me
that we're not going to run out of them
briefly my my problem with identity
politics which I would define as a
single-minded obsession with viewing
everything in life in all of human
history through the prism of the rivalry
and power relationships between groups
my problem with that is that it's
flattening its
it's an ugly dismal way of looking at
being a wife and it's it's an ugly way
of thinking of both the self and of
other people those are related we all
have selves but according to identity
politics the only thing that matters
about anyone here is your race your
gender whether or not you're disabled
what your sexual preference are and and
whether you're you're satisfied with
your gender
in fact we identity politics has
fractured so much that these categories
of people who are implicitly pitted
against each other for your sympathy are
infinitely subdividing and that's the
second problem with this way of looking
at the world is that it's fundamentally
adversarial and so it pits us all
against each other and ironically it
pits its all against each other and the
weirdest of spectrums which is who's
more oppressed who who has it the
hardest it's not about becoming powerful
it is about it's about seeing your
powerlessness as your power and that
kind of inversion weirdly means that
people who regard themselves as
oppressed have no reason to get
unimpressed that is to solve their
problem because their problem is there
their ticket their gravy train that's
where all your power is weakness is
power disadvantages advantage and so
that we are we are encouraging people to
embrace their own fragility and their
own difficulties as their as the source
of their very identity
I don't disagree with any of this I
don't imagine we're gonna disagree on
anything we're gonna have to find
something what Lionel describes I
noticed in recent years
beginning with the phenomenon of
speaking as a maybe it'll even happening
cue a later shot in the foot if you do
do that but speaking as a is is one of
the ways in which you start to sense
this movement speaking as a woman
speaking as a nobody of course is
speaking as a man but speaking as a gay
speaking as a person of color and so on
and so forth is the start of this this
movement which I think has been
weaponized politicized to an incredibly
dangerous degree in recent years I
describe it in the madness of crowds as
being like in the last 15 years in
particular like seeing a set of rights
claims women's rights equal rights for
people whatever their sexual orientation
equal rights for everyone whatever their
origins as looking like seeing a train
coming into a station that it was meant
to arrive in ad and just as it looked
like it was arriving in at the desired
destination suddenly getting a head of
steam going shooting off down the tracks
off the tracks and then scattering
people in its wake why I started to
wonder when the situation of all rights
claims had never been better
where all of them presented as if
they've never been worse
why should everything have taken on this
retributive manner why the worst thing
that can happen to any liberation
movement is getting what it wants yes
yes well they they become like the
phenomenon we see in charities this this
happens in the charitable sector you set
up a charity to deal with a particular
disease if they cure the disease or a
disease the disease has a cure found for
it the charity always finds a way to
continue it will become the charity for
people who once had that disease or knew
someone who had it and because by this
point pensions were involved and and
careers and much more so we see the
thing now of I mean there was a time
needless to say
for instance gay rights groups civil
rights boots in America and so on had a
point now what is the point of these
entities other than to claim that
they've never been so oppressed that
it's never been worse that everything's
about to get much worse than we know and
then this strange weaponization of
everybody against everyone else so that
the gays are used against the straights
and the women against the men did in the
Train that's trans against everyone yes
I mean just total war and people of
different racial backgrounds against
each other so that we now see and we'll
get onto this but we now see the the
epithet white and all of these
derivation which is pejorative solely
pejorative so I suggested to Lionel one
of the ways we might approach this
tonight what she says is to follow the
way I do it in the matters of crowds but
to invite each other to tread on to all
of these landmines one by one I say
there that what I want to do and I
should just say one of these fortunate
things about being a writer I should
also say thank you for being a writer
the spectator is that you can say what
you think without repercussion and
increasingly in our society that isn't
the case we see extraordinary situations
people losing their jobs for stating
very basic truths that everyone agreed
until 48 hours ago weird cases I can as
the worker sacked for sharing a Billy
Connelly video so my view is that
writers have a disproportionate duty
therefore in such a situation to tell
the truth is that a lot of other people
are increasingly unable to say and the
analogy I use some of you may know is an
analogy of a device I discovered the
British Army uses the pool it's called a
great Viper and you pull it on the back
of a truck to the edge of a minefield
and then you you fire this huge missile
and it goes over minefield but this long
explosive tail
as it lands over the whole thing then it
detonates in one go
the analogy came to mind because this
can't clear all the mines but it can
make it safer for people to cross the
field which is I would submit one of the
points of people like lying on me doing
what we do is to try to speak and say
the things that we need to be thinking
about although not to denigrate either
of our excellence one of the reasons
we're here is that a lot of other people
aren't that is I I will speak especially
for my colleagues who are fiction
writers they have gone along with this
movement to an alarming degree and I
find myself really out in the cold in
relation to all this material and while
I have gone ahead and merrily written
whatever I feel like for The Spectator
and good for Fraser for publishing it I
sometimes wonder whether that's because
I'm brave or that's because I'm stupid
this is a very dangerous movement and it
has become predatory and I have a couple
of times now come within its sights and
I've got away with my skin but if it
went up another notch I could easily see
publishers leery of putting my work out
what's the newest you've come oh well of
course there's a contest between the two
one of them was more UK centered and one
of them was International the
International one was when I poked fun
of of cultural appropriation and in in
Brisbane Australia and it was the first
time that a conversation has got going
on
this topic and everyone went bananas but
it was more the UK one that I think
struck the fear of God into my UK
publishers and that was when I wrote
about the penguin Random House plan to
to make their to make both their authors
lists and their staff perfectly
reflective of the UK population in
relation to gender class race ethnicity
sexual preference and disability I'm
sure I've left some out but and and this
was such an absurd project when it you
know their job is to sell books not to
reflect the UK population so I made fun
of it and but the sense it did have to
do with diversity you know you don't
make jokes in the area of diversity
that's what really got me into trouble
the column was funny dance
and so they they took it one line in
particular out of context and it went
crazy on social media it helped there
was a firewall up on the spectator so
that they they couldn't read the whole
column not knowing what you're talking
about is a big assist for these people
and and you know I was white widely
decried as a racist and my father the
civil rights activist would be surprised
perhaps a bit disappointed and ever
since then I mean I you know I'm sure
you've suffered the same thing you know
you eventually these insults start just
its water off a duck's back you know so
you know tell me oh right
you know it was a literary white
supremacist trying to smuggle white
supremacy back through the medium of the
novel right yeah
it's a long game that one damn so far it
hasn't worked there's of course there's
a restaurant hland Oregon that was open
for about a fortnight it was called
Safran colonial and it was shut down
because it was accused because it had
the term colonial in the title of trying
to bring back colonialism and I said
about that well again it seems like an
unlikely way to start colonialism the
long march via Portland restaurants now
if we want to talk about gays I have one
question for you I'm curious to what
degree do you rely on being gay yourself
in order to have standing to talk about
some of these subjects do you find
yourself using it in an almost
manipulative manner gosh
I'm gonna get you for that he thought
this was gonna be friendly yeah yeah it
might be for anyone else to judge but
where I'm sitting here's what I think I
actually start the madness of crowds
with the gay chapter for a number of
reasons one is there something systemic
that's important about it which is that
I think that on each of the litmus test
issues that all of the real difficult
issues of our time they all fall into
one of two categories either they're
things that we pretend we know lots
about which we don't know much about or
they're things we all know about or knew
about till yesterday which we've
forgotten so gay and trans we've tend to
know a lot about and in fact they're
pretty mysterious things still relations
between the sexes is clearly because
we're all here aren't a total mystery we
knew about them for quite a long time
and now pretend not to know or pretend
to have instilled a new set of ethics in
it so I for a systematic reason I
thought it was in
de-stress this by doing gay first but
you're right to put your finger on this
this issue because to some extent yes I
wanted to say look if I'm willing to
pull apart and look at and stress the
difficulty of gay and this is the one
issue which I have my crampons on on the
edifice of a man right then then I
wanted to say look if I'm if I'm willing
to explore the difficult things we still
don't know about about gays for instance
then trust me that I'm not being
insincere in doing the same thing on
other issues like what I was getting at
that you were establishing standing
there's nothing wrong with that I mean I
use the word manipulative in a
manipulative manner but ultimately you
use what you've got yeah my view is I
say you know as a way to show that if I
critique this were indeed a couple of
gay friends have said to me I don't
think you should have said some of the
things you said in that chapter because
for instance I talked about this this
thing of hardware/software one of the
few ethics that we've agreed on in our
society is don't go for people for
hardware issues so you know one of the
reasons in my others which we agree that
you know you wouldn't be rude to
somebody who's disabled among much else
is it's not like they chose to be
disabled that's a hardware thing there's
nothing they could do about that one of
the things that's interesting in the
ethics we've been creating in the West
has been in recent years that because of
this a lot of issues are auditioning to
be seen as Hardware issues so gays
auditioned very clearly campaigned to
say look it's because people said born
because people said lifestyle choice the
obvious play - lifestyle choices well
it's obviously not a lifestyle choice
because who would choose to make their
life a bit harder was to say no born
this way the Lady Gaga option and the
problem with the Born This Way thing is
it's a sensible tactical play but it's
not quite true because we still don't
quite know but everything wants to be
hardware because it's then harder to
critique trans at the moment is
presenting itself as hardware because if
it's Hardware who would with no proof
hardly oh no proof of hardware and here
of course we'll get on this here's the
really difficult one is that trans says
we're hardware at the same time saying
being a woman is software you can have
one of those programs but not both you
can't say the only people legitimately
born the way they are are trans people
but yes I said I the several people said
to me I don't think you should have
opened up this whole born this way thing
with gays but I wanted to show look it
doesn't affect my sense of self
if tomorrow a gay gene was discovered or
tomorrow they said this is purely a
nurture thing it wouldn't affect
anything in my sense of myself because I
haven't built my sense of myself or
identity on the fact that I happen to be
gay but yes have I ever used it no I
think not because I've never been given
an inch of privilege by my critics for
this fact no one on the left ever the
Guardian has never said come on give dog
with a break he's gay Oh at least if if
they have then I wasn't reading it that
day so well I was struck by something
you said a few sentences ago that you
don't Center your identity around being
gay and I think that's one of the things
one of the things that's important about
the gay movement it's one of its great
successes is that in the early days when
you met someone who was gay
that was enough that was who they were
that was an identity and it's kind of
thin you know as is something to cling
to that it's not a full-time job it
would be a pretty exhausting full-time
job and and frankly for straight people
at least it became a little trying and I
think for gay people it became a little
trying because all gay people are not
the same and they don't all necessarily
have a lot in common I mean this is the
way identity politics in
in it encourages you to think that these
are all homogeneous groups and they all
have the same interests and and they're
all politically the same you get it that
in your book and they're not all
politically the same they're just not
all the same and these group memberships
don't give you much they're a starting
point in and and if you're if you are a
true individual they're often a starting
point that you may form yourself in
opposition to they are the parts of your
life that you don't have control over
you and especially if you accept that
gay is hardware then that's yet one more
thing you were born into and I don't I
am in opposition to this whole movement
because these categories don't satisfy
my sense of identity I don't I don't
cling to being white or female or
American or able-bodied or any of all
the categories I was born into was
something that I wanted to break free of
or be larger than when one of the
pleasures of my life for example has
been leaving the United States making my
home here I'm still American I've never
lived it down but I made my world larger
and you know in some ways getting
married to a man made my world larger
you know I I care about both both sexes
when I had having having friends who are
of another race it makes my world larger
why would we want to cling to our own
little cages or stay in your lane which
is one of the phrases that's used that's
you've got to stay in your lane I don't
veer away from the group you're in don't
talk about groups you're not in you know
if you're a man you have no right to
talk about women because why would men
be interested in women and don't talk
about people of a country that you're
not from I mean and just put that back
on you I'm
if somebody said Oh Lionel you're my
favorite female novelist oh it's an
insult yeah yeah yeah yeah
profound himself because it then says
right I see you first and foremost as a
woman but have you ever had that used
against you or used it
I mean de-facto
publishing divides into female riders
who are implicitly writing for women and
male writers who were writing for
everyone so and it's it's mostly done
it's mostly expressed through packaging
and and publicity and I I i hate that
category I may take a little too much
satisfaction in men who read my books
but it is a big relief when I discovered
that there is a male readership for my
fiction and I admire men who crossed the
gender divide and are willing to read
female writers because they pretty much
don't you know the women chapter in my
book I'm mainly interested in this thing
of why women are being weaponized
against men and specifically why we've
been falling into telling a set of
things we must know to be untrue or
holding an untrue set of positions so
that I have this suggestion that
simultaneously at the moment in our
culture we hold several views we say
women and men are exactly the same and
women are magically better on occasion
the christine lagarde ism if it had been
Lehman sisters she keeps saying then the
crash might not have happened is it but
why I mean it's a fascinating thing to
try to unpack why is it that they're
better are they more cautious if so
where would you deploy the cautious
women but it's not that it's
simultaneously just exactly the same and
some
times better well of course
I have always clung to the solution to
this constant argument about whether
there are big differences or whether
that were the same by not even needing
scientific evidence but looking around
me and verifying that the variations
within the sexes are so much more
drastic than the very eighth variations
on average between the sexes then I'm
not going to lose any sleep over it I
mean it in fact there's an interesting
[Music]
there was an interesting piece in
collect recently I hope you saw it and
it had two bell curves set by side by
side and one of them was the qualities
that are associated with femininity and
and how female women are there was that
bell curve and then there was how male
men are and there was that bell curve
well the intersection was huge and the
tails of both of them went into the far
range of the other and if you can I
don't know whether I'm I'm getting this
picture across right but the point is
that there are very masculine women who
are far more masculine than men and
there are very feminine men who are far
more feminine than women and this is
without getting surgery and I think the
whole part of the whole trans movement
is responding to this complexity I I'll
of complexity I'm a novelist I think and
I and and and I think it it makes life
more interesting and it makes our
relationships more complex and
furthermore I'm not entirely happy with
the whole idea of male and female
characteristics there may be a rough
accuracy to them I'm not gonna fight it
but I don't think of myself as
especially soft and passive
I'm not going to dispute that but one of
the things we seem to be struggling over
is how do you how do you form a society
in which nobody should be held back if
they've got a competence in a particular
area irrespective of their sex or sexual
orientation or race or anything else how
do you make sure that nobody is held
back without doing things like mandatory
quotas because occasionally in recent
months people said to me you know a lot
of this identity politics stuff you go
on about is it's a kind of university
graduate problem it's a Berkeley
University problem it's a West Coast
liberal arts thing and I've started to
realize that the only people who say
that to me are people who are
self-employed or retired because almost
everybody in the world of work notices
now that this is for coming for them the
recruiting process is in search of
making sure nobody is held back if
they've got a competency because of an
identity issue are moving to let's put
the identity issue first and foremost
and then go on to the competency if we
like well I mean that's why I got in so
much trouble for that column about
penguin Random House yeah the United
States has been dealing what we call
with what we call affirmative action or
positive discrimination if you will for
50 years
and it hasn't worked out very well so
this is one of those rare instances
where I come in as an American and tell
you what to do don't make the same
mistake the UK has traditionally been
resistant to solving problems of
inequality between groups by
artificially manhandling those groups
into a quota systems but along with
identity politics has come the sudden
popular
of this kind of privilege if you to use
the favorite word of the movement
privilege in what you are over who you
are and how good you are at whatever
you're supposed to be hired to do and
same thing in education it's a disaster
and it's a disaster for the very people
you want to help as well as everyone
else and I think this is this this is
one of the things that so-called social
justice warriors don't wrestle with they
don't understand how complicated social
justice really is after all the reason
that social the the that we have law
books this big is because social justice
is really complicated and hard to work
out so that it just to come along and
simplistically decide of oh well blacks
have been discriminated against so we're
just going to hire a bunch more blacks
and we're going to publish all their
books and and we're gonna put all these
black people into universities and then
everything will be fine well that's just
not the way it works I mean and it's
unfair on a couple of levels it's unfair
to the people whom you displace who may
be better qualified and they didn't
create the inequality right they just
were born into it as as everyone else
and it's also unfair to the very people
you're trying to help because look
they're not stupid if you have a quota
system so that's why they were hired
that's why they got into this school
that doesn't make you feel good that
doesn't create personal esteem and
furthermore there's a larger
contamination of the assumptions in the
whole society which has really permeated
the United States now frankly you meet a
black lawyer and you figure he got into
school because he was black and that is
evil yeah you know that is perpetuating
racism you know that's what it does so
don't do it
your chart Charles and Charles Marino
relation mentioned this recently in an
interview he said that when he was at
Harvard in the 70s if he saw a black
student he thought wow you must be smart
I mean you must you must be really smart
to be here you know you have worked
harder and everything else to get here
and he said he couldn't help thinking
that this generation of students would
be looking at such a person and say
somehow gerrymandered yeah and all the
follow-on thoughts of that causes and
we've seen recently the phenomenon of
Harvard and the admissions scandal
precisely on this and if any of you have
not followed this oh just a second this
is this is an example of one of the
ugliest things of our time that you open
up and this is this is one of the
reasons why I'm urging people not to
play the identity politics game because
we don't entirely know what we unearth
when we start this Harvard thought that
it was going to improve admissions for
among others african-americans and what
some been uncovered in the last couple
of years because a group of Asian
students have taken Harvard to the
courts it's called a what's the name of
the group anyhow they've come together
to take out a lawsuit against Harvard
because what they discovered was at
Harvard University was in order to try
to be more racially fair was downgrading
Asian applicants to Harvard and what
turned out in the discovery process was
that they would they were doing so
before even interviewing Asian students
and they were downgrading them and by
the way Harvard fought like anything to
try to stop this coming out they said
that this was their tricks of the trade
this was a you know secret well yeah it
was and the secret was that they were
downgrading Asian applicants before
meeting them on character
traits yes they would get characterized
as passive lacking in quality yeah yeah
unimaginative yeah interestingly it did
play to the cliche of what Asians are
white because it was an entirely racist
it was incredibly racist but you know it
wasn't even racist I mean in other words
it was purely manipulative it was purely
in order to get their scores down
because the Asians were coming in with
these near perfect SAT scores that
college admission test and you know the
truth is they were they they work too
hard and if you look at what's happened
in California which has banned by
referendum using race in admissions
meaning that people really are getting
in on the basis of their test scores and
their ability the Asians have basically
taken over the state's university system
and by the way more power to them I
think it's fantastic you know if if
they're gonna work that hard and apply
themselves that much and make that many
sacrifices when other teenagers are out
you know kiting around and having fun
then they should be rewarded and well
but one of the most interesting things
about the Asian story in in in general
it's not just in education they're doing
fantastically well in the United States
and also here is it is it really
spanners the whole reasoning of
affirmative action
no because you cannot argue especially
in the United States that Asians have
not been discriminated against maybe
there we passed something called the
Chinese Exclusion Act in in the 1880s
specifically keeping Asian people out
and there was terrible discrimination
against them and and grotesque
stereotypes and
interestingly you know you fast forward
to today we've got some of the similar
problems with hostility and stereotypes
although this time because you know the
Chinese are taking over the world so
that's why that's why Americans are
remained often quite hostile to agents
but if you have this this identity group
that has been historically discriminated
against and often their parents are poor
and and and immigrants shouldn't they be
doing really badly with unless you give
them special help they've got not only
are they not getting special help but
they're being actively discriminated
against because because their test
scores are too good yeah so it ruins the
whole model yeah in the great oppression
Olympics it doesn't help
it's it's like in America we have the
whole reparations debate now it's an
incredibly painful debate but I've often
said to American friends if you start
going down this road of looking at who
historically has been prejudiced against
in by the way history wasn't great for
anyone by and large you know but if you
start playing that game you could agree
you could end up having to agree that
among the most oppressed people in
history perhaps the most oppressed were
the Jews and and would you want to go
house to house and collect money from
everyone to give it to the Jews you
might spark a new type of problem where
you do to insist upon that in certain
communities and but it's the sort of
thing we start open up and by the way I
wanted to know ask you about it to a
great extent the racial issues which now
coming back and weapon I seem to me to
be to a great extent a spillover from
American racial issues it's very
striking to me the sort of globalization
of a specific American racial issue and
I mean there's an example anyhow I gave
it in my last book when when black lives
matter came to London a few years ago
whatever the rights and wrongs of that
movement in the u.s. it was surreal to
see black lives matter about a thousand
or 2,000 people marching I went to the
protest marching down Oxford Street with
her hands in the air doing the black
lives matter thing of hands up don't
shoot all all escorted by unarmed
British police officers shot they wanted
to you know and and I just thought I
just thought well whatever the rights
and wrongs this in America why would you
be doing this here yes endless issues in
the race things seem to be like that
well the UK does have an unfortunate
tendency to imitate and and of course
that's that imitation is fired by social
media a lot of what we're talking about
today is now Western wide I mean it's
it's true of the British diaspora also
you know almost the whole Commonwealth
Canada Ireland and Australia also have
really rabid hard left identity politics
movements in them so and they're you
know all these people are in
communication with each other and the
internet and so so in some ways we can't
talk about Paula Dee's as separate
anymore the contamination has really
accelerated and but I have to say that
you know one of the problems with this
whole movement is that it's regressive
and I feel it's really ramming us into
her verse you use that image of a train
going forward and off the tracks but in
some ways it's screeching to a halt and
running backwards because a lot of the
issues that we're talking and we've
about we you know we've made great
strides on and now I feel like I'm in
I'm into a time machine
yeah you know so there are even on the
gender in front with women I I feel as
if we have fought this battle over and
over again after all we keep calling it
a different wave
but it's it's it's a wave that's
crashing in place we're keep having the
same argument over and over again and
meanwhile things get better with races
somehow even more poisonous and I've
noticed they show we have made
considerable strides with racial
discrimination in the United States yet
at the same time if you look at the
newspapers you'd think that it was worse
than it's ever been yeah
and indeed the polls show that most
Americans think that it is worse
especially white liberals and in fact it
in they've documented that in 2010
twenty five percent of American white
liberals believed that race and racial
discrimination was a huge problem for
the country six years later it was
fifty-eight percent among the same
people so something weird has happened
and what's especially weird is that
American liberals are more upset about
race relationship equations in the
United States then blacks and Hispanics
are and they think it's worse and I'm
afraid that's where we get down to one
of the core qualities of this movement I
mean it sounds as if it's the all these
different separate groups clamoring to
be heard and clamoring for their rights
and there's an element of that but
overwhelmingly the the group that's
really and each other's throats is white
people white liberals white liberals are
behind this movement not you know
discriminated against black people or
whatever it is
liberals competing with each other who
can be more righteous and you know it
oddly
[Applause]
oddly the people who are most woke and
who used the term privileged in in that
pejorative sense which means you have to
shut the [ __ ] up they are overwhelmingly
white affluent and well-educated in
other words they are the privileged
right
it's the privileged who are telling
other white people to shut the Kaaba and
the irony is the irony of this you know
self-selected elite is that they're
getting down on everyone else for being
privileged
but what they really want is more
privilege for themselves
it is a kind of green because on top of
having all the money and the great
education and all the status that's not
enough for them they have to have the
moral high ground yeah
this is the this is one of the
explanations for the phenomenon of
circled woke capitalism I suggested
after the crash of 2008 actually
corporate America and corporate Britain
found it rather easy to start playing
this game because it was a way to show
that you were paying indulgences to the
religion of your time without actually
having to take account for mistakes
you'd made so you could you would say
yeah of course we'll make sure the
diversity officer does a bit more of
this and we get the as I've discovered
at an alarming number of corporations
will get the intersectional stuff going
because it'll show that we're playing
the game of the time by the way I mean
one of the other things about this which
is worth mentioning for moat is that is
that this keeps happening in each of
these areas so that some people work out
what the game is and play it very well
the ones I'm worried about are
particularly young people who it's
already hard enough to work out what a
game of life is and then there's this
extra layer of complexity needlessly put
on the top of it I give the example in
in relations between the sexes of of the
the analogy from nature of the
cuttlefish which I've become rather
interested in a biologist friend
introduced me to the cuttlefish because
a particular type of cuttlefish has an
extraordinary thing it it's it's like a
mimic octopus it has a way of changing
its form in order to adapt an
environment it's in now specifically
there's a bad female to male ratio in
the cuttlefish community and they are
they work as consorts so a male will
accompany a female and will make sure
that the female isn't accessed shall we
say by competitors this makes it hard
for the male cuttlefish and the
important thing to bear in mind here is
that the males are larger than the
females so what happens the male
cuttlefish has developed a way to look
like a female it makes itself smaller
more diminutive and it sidles up whilst
the male cuttlefish is thinking okay
there's no competition gets under the
meat and a female cuttlefish and then
has its wicked cuttlefish way and
when I was told this by that biologist
friend I just said oh my god I've seen
this so much and I was specifically
reminded of my friend and colleague at
spectator Freddie gray who covered the
women's march in Washington just after
the inauguration of President Trump and
he told me I think you've heard about
this in the spectator that he'd folded
the whole day he gets back to an
after-party and he's in a sort of dorm
like party with some women had been on
the protests with various men they were
sort of the Ivy League equivalent of the
Soviet ago yeah that was like such a
totally brilliant March and so they were
doing that and he described to me how
they were all wearing their pink hats
and everything and and whilst the women
were there the guys are all doing that
yo yo [ __ ] Trump and the moment the
moment the last woman left of the group
one of the guys went to the others oh my
god I can't believe how much action
there is in this room okay he used that
choice you say slightly rude a term
which I won't use for speak to the
audience but um but at the moment that
Freddie told me about I thought yeah of
course this is pure cuttlefish and
behavior you you pretend that you go
along with the whole thing you you
feminized yourself a bit you present
yourself as a sort of harmless little
man and then you can get in and get the
action well the problem is a lot of
young men haven't worked that out and
the ones you have are disproportionately
privileged actually as you say
privileged rich well educated and have
sussed the game of the era and are
playing it so damn well this seems to me
among other things incredibly unfair on
a lot of people but we should by the way
we've we haven't got any shortage of
things to talk about but we should get
on to my favorite issue I want to ask
you one oh go on
question no no before we move on to
trans because if we don't this audience
will write
but why we were back on women hmm you've
generally been identified with the
intellectual dark web it's just a loose
confederation of people who do a lot of
events and podcasts together and they're
not insane I think that's a good that
kind of you I want to know why you think
there are almost no women in that
movement such an interesting point first
these are very loosely described
secondly there are some Christina Hoff
Sommers for instance then there's
christina hoff sommers and as i recall
there's also christina off summers I
mean it's astonishing I look I admit
that when the writings not going very
well I do sometimes go to YouTube and it
is remarkably consistent now I should
say before you get all defensive that
you know in a funny way I admire it
because you insofar as there you have
any coherence as a group and you're not
Confederated or incorporated you are not
responding to any perceived pressure to
5050 or to have more women you have
resisted any tokenism and I like that
you know I appreciate that so I'd like a
fuller explanation of why you think that
this is somehow ends up being a very
male pushback movement is it because
women don't push back enough I think
there might be two things the first
might be a agree ability issue mmm a
character traits issue could be a
disagree ability issue a second and I
think this is worth mentioning
is and we hear this in politics we don't
hear it enough in this direction but let
me do this by mention the trans thing in
this I mentioned in the trans chapter in
this book what I think is the most
reasonable humane way of trying to
understand something we haven't been
talking about or thinking about at all
well but here's the thing I've said a
lot of things and written a lot of
things about the trans thing which I've
expected a lot of pushback on and I've
got a bit but again it's water off a
duck's back but here's the thing that's
very interesting to me the people who
are most angry about the trans thing
when you say things that we know to be
true about it the pushback is
extraordinarily strong against women and
I think this reveals something
interesting about that movement in
particular the trans movement keeps it's
dominated by male to female trans and
I've been pretty much left alone with
what I've said about this and I just
that surprises me but then I told you I
predicted in my review of your book that
the only people who would buy it were
the people who already agreed with it
it's possible I'm hoping it's not
although I believe that's a lot of
people yeah I want the people who don't
think they can agree with me on this to
take this one as seriously as possible
because if not we are in the midst of
doing something which future generations
are going to look back on and say they
did want there's a seven-year-old boy in
Texas at the moment as you know parents
arguing about what gender the child is
the mother wants to transition the child
from male to female because he liked
Disney's frozen at the age of five and
the father says no I have a son and
they're fighting for this they're
fighting fists and this is the sort of
thing that future generations will look
back on say they did what in 2019 in the
name of kindness of course because we
always look back on history and think
well they must have done stuff because
they were evil know again and again
people did the things that were worst
whilst thinking they were being
kind so this this issue is so live and
we need to think about it but I am so
struck that time and again and I list
the extraordinary women who've held
their ground on this one time and again
the the target of the most virulent
trans activists are women now there is
so much in this you can unpack but it
happened a few weeks ago in Manchester
where a group of women's rights
activists have a meeting and male to
female transsexual are banging on the
windows whilst the police are standing
around allowing it whilst these women to
being intimidated in the building now
what is this well several things one is
and let's be frank about this one is
deep disgust hatred and envy of people
born with them in definitely going on
and a double hatred and it's interesting
that disgust an envy go together that's
counterintuitive short and this is being
this has been duly bindle I mentioned
the book female lesbian activist who's
been campaigning for women in prison and
much more for decades can't go anywhere
without a trans protest against her
Julie Burchill when she writes about
trans I mean Julie says this is one of
the things that she thinks sent her
career down the Kazi Germaine Greer gets
it on there of course Jemaine Greer
isn't a feminist anymore and and on and
on the list of the main people they have
gone for and targeted of women and I
think that that just must end up having
an effect and I just enormous ly admire
the woman's still willing to to make the
case because you know one of the things
that's so interesting about the
intersectional era and the
intersectional claims is that they are
demonstrably untrue on their own
estimation of themselves so the idea of
this horrible sounding movement of
intersection lists is that if you the
whole of our society is a set of
interlocking oppressions and if you
unlock one of these oppressions you
unlock all of them it takes no account
of the fact that a lots of these alleged
oppressions run completely against each
other so for instance you say that the
slightly effeminate boy is actually a
or you say that the tomboy girl who
might grow up to be a lesbian on my grew
up to be heterosexual 80% of people
diagnosed with gender dysphoria turn out
not to have gender dysphoria but you do
this and you are running straight
against some very fundamental things of
the women's liberation and women's
rights movement of recent decades you
are running very fundamentally against
the gay rights and gay liberation
movement rescind a case and this is only
just being realized so what I say to the
intersection lists is even on the basis
of your own claim about society works
you are creating a car crash what's
extraordinary what I find most
extraordinary about the transgender
movement which really only got going in
about 2012 would you say it's
extraordinary rapidity there's a
rapidity with which it not only took
over socially and culturally but even
institutionally in governmentally so
that it was suddenly in our schools yeah
and you are asking five-year-olds which
gender they want to be yeah but the
other thing that's extraordinary about
it is along with this rush of you know
media obsession you know you turn on the
TV five different transgender
documentaries on it once what came in at
the same time was what we all understood
you can't talk about it you can't talk
about it you can't say a discouraging
word about it and even if you were very
suspicious of it and and worried that
people were making rash and irrevocable
decisions that they might regret you
knew you had to keep your mouth shut and
I think that's one of the things that
Douglas and I are trying to break
through I think that's one of the
reasons it was important for you to
include that chapter we have to be able
to talk about it especially now that we
are mutilating and putting on drugs
which
affects we we have no idea our children
children and if it didn't involve
children I think the urgency would be
somewhat less but this obsession this
trend this it's really become a kind of
fetish is potentially doing a lot of
harm to people who aren't old enough to
know what they're doing yeah yeah I I
couldn't be more we we should come to
the audience questions I suggest by the
way we we save our what to do about it
till the end of Q&A but I just mentioned
one other thing in the meantime if I'm
area which is I think the trans one is
particularly interesting because it
reveals something about this whole
movement I say about this that it's very
striking when a movement is trying to
gain following or acceptance it's very
interesting how it makes its moves and
the trans movement did something
fascinating which I think hasn't been
identified enough it if you wanted to
make a rights claim in this area you
would make the rights claim for intersex
that is people born with indeterminate
genitalia because it's it's a hardware
issue and it's a it's not the work it's
not a great way to start your life it's
a very suboptimal situation to be in I
think it's real and it's real you can
see it it's real and I reckon you could
get a very legitimate reasonable and
indeed pretty broad consensus of people
to agree that these people need more
help and understanding about them here's
the interesting thing trans jumped all
the way over intersex never bothered
with doing intersex went all the way to
say the big bearded man with a penises
of weightlifting champion in the women's
bit or you're a bigot and that's it's
it's just it's an appalling way to try
to build a coalition so what I realized
when looking into this was something I
think it's rather significant they're
not trying to build a coalition they're
not trying to do that they are using
trans as a battering ram the same thing
they've been trying to use women for
same thing they've been trying to use
the gays for same thing they're trying
to use different races for what is the
battering ram I would suggest it's
something like this and by the way some
people this is I say this in the Marxism
chapter in some people this is
completely straightforward it is post
Cold War smuggling Marxism in through a
new way undermine everything about this
society say that being gay is merely the
first step to undermining capitalism
saying that being a woman cannot be
addressed unless we also bring down the
free market say that that we live in the
most sexist society the most racist
society the most unfair society do all
of these things say that we don't know
what men and women are undermine every
single basis of truth that we understand
demoralize everyone long enough that
then they don't resist when you come in
with your fully prepared Marxist plan
now some of that
[Applause]
in some people in some people in some
people that is completely clear and I
give examples of the people who said
that absolutely explicitly at the end of
the Cold War we need to use minority
groups to do what the working class
ended up not doing for us but other
people are simply being misled this is
my update I have to side with the misled
I mean uh that's a neat theory but the
way you keep talking about they I don't
know who you're talking about I don't
know I don't know who sensibly in
control here i-i can see how you can
parse the way it works out as benefiting
a kind of Marxist ideology or the it
being a kind of retread of Marxist
ideology but that's different from
saying that there's some Authority or
cabal of people controlling you know I
don't I don't agree with that I think
misguided is the name of the day in fact
I think it's important at some point in
this event to say that most of the
people who have got caught up in this
way of thinking they're not maligned and
they're responding to a natural human
need for purpose for meaning and even
for justice I am NOT going to discount
the real desire of a lot of people who
feel passionately about these things for
justice I think their version of justice
is simplistic and potentially unjust but
that's not to say that that their
motivation is wicked in any way and
therefore I think they're misguided and
it's I think one of the best things that
you officer observed in your book was it
had a tenderness to it that that kind of
understanding for what what the movement
is is is feeding what these kind of
appetites said that what's wrong with it
is that it's something of a dead end
it's it's spiritually uh nutritious
yeah in that flattening of the world and
it's a waste of their time yeah and when
you get a little older you realize how
precious that is we should come to the
audience quite now I can't remember how
the system of questions works but we're
not responsible for it either Lionel or
I and I think I just follow the lady
number one over there okay there's
somebody there and if I could just so if
I just said a usual housekeeping things
spent a provenza's please give a
question to a sentence with a question
mark at the end thank very much
so just touching on historical
comparisons just for me if you think we
can draw historical comparisons to what
we're seeing and indeed we can draw
comfort from that have we not seen this
before
for example example that comes to mind
is the counterculture around the Vietnam
War very feeble Tom in politics but can
we not draw comfort from the fact that
that movement did fade away and maybe
this movement will fade away as well
thank you yes I do take comfort that I
have seen other movements come and go
and I am hopeful that we will look back
on this period as particularly febrile
and that something ran out of control
mm-hmm if we don't look back on this
period as particularly febrile that's
really bad news because it means that
later it got even worse I think the one
thing that grounded the movements in the
60s and early 70s was as you mentioned
the Vietnam War and that was something
substantive that really mattered to
people who went off and fought it and
didn't believe in it and damaged a lot
of people and damaged a lot of families
and it made it you know somehow more
palpable more real it it there was
something it was about something more
than just free
than sex it-it-it grounded that whole
time and and and of course it was also
in the heels of the civil rights
movement which changed the world in a
very good way and now we're dealing with
a weird kind of backlash residue of that
same movement but I'm with you you know
I mean I we were going to talk about
what there was to do about this and
honestly my the to me the most likely
thing that knocks identity politics out
because I believe it to be the result of
prosperity it's a first world problem
it's people not having enough to do with
themselves what's gonna knock it out is
is something really awful happening I
wish I wish I could come up with
something else but that's often what
nots movements off is either something
good comes along not very often but
something awful happens and you have to
concern yourself with other problems and
I suspect that's what's gonna happen
with us yeah my question is do you think
the Democrat Party in this United States
and the Labour Party in this country
have embraced identity politics as a way
of maintaining control on the minority
vote yes yes number three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
would you I mean I would just together
the striking things going on in politics
among other things yes the left-wing
parties have broadly speaking latched on
to this because it's it's what they hope
they say the groups that didn't turn up
in the Cold War for them or let them
down this provides something very useful
with if any of you saw the LGBT town
hall that the Democratic Party had the
other week it's something to behold
don't watch the whole thing but it's
it's um it's actually an asylum outbreak
it's beyond anything you've seen and it
ignores the fact that frankly on some of
these issues we are dealing with very
unwell people literally grabbing the mic
literally grabbing the mic
yes and I think this whole thing the
whole thing of rhetoric in this this
weird thing that's come in in Britain
again in recent weeks which we all know
knowing we mustn't mention the B word
probably but but but it's extraordinary
thing where it works one way round but
not the other you know so there's
basically nothing you can't say about
the prime minister or Dominic Cummings
but one mean thing about one labor that
venture and it's it's
I'm just trying to get as many people as
soon as possible so stairs yeah okay
number five the question regards to
Douglas and your latest two books if I
could sort of compare them to me the
strange death of Europe through telling
a story of immigration you touch on the
importance of two types of moral groups
in terms of being a source of our
identity it's a a national group and a
religious group as a source of identity
and then in this book it's the sort of a
moral or immoral sources of identity
from a group through race gender and
sexual orientation so just my question
is what sort of distinctions do you make
between a moral source of a group
identity and an immoral or amoral source
of quick question I mean I I would say
it's this yes there are only a few
things you can do identity from you can
do it from religious affiliation you can
do it with national affiliation you can
do it with group identity affiliation
one of the reasons I criticize it is
because as Lionel's already said I mean
it's its enormous Lee reductive and it's
it's pretty shallow one of the
advantages I'm not I'm not a nationalist
or anything but I think the nation is a
is its virtue is among other things
apart from as Roger Scruton says the
largest extension of the first-person
plural that you can do the we apart from
that also the largest extension you can
claim some kind of pride in but that you
do actually have some involvement in
it's it's also a it's also the nation
among other things is not bad of course
it goes up it can go wrong like
everything the nation isn't a bad source
of meaning also because it forces you to
engage with people who you may not
otherwise have anything in common with
and the identity groupings they're
exactly the opposite of they're they say
you only having things in common with
the one group that you are a part of and
it's a sex sexual orientation racial or
other group
and I simply think that this is among
other things an incredibly shallow way
to do it which also inevitably will
weaponize we know how how nations can be
weaponized against each other we're
pretty familiar with that we're not very
good at recognizing how identity groups
of this kind can use the insular and
I've just urge people particularly young
people not to play this game or to get
out of this game as fast as they can and
to get their lives onto it something
which will give them real meaning
because they can't find it here they're
being engaged they're being invited to
play a game that's unwinnable and is
profoundly wasting of their lives and
let me just make one other point in that
one of the things that troubles me so
much about this is that we keep skipping
over issues of meaning in pursuit of
this so for instance and I say this in
the chapter on women feminism as Camille
Paglia and many other people have said
never dealt with the issue of motherhood
properly didn't know what to do with it
and it it it parked it it's a hell of a
thing to park and that's the problem
there are all of these things we could
do with thinking about better and we're
wasting our energies and we're wasting
our time I would add that I I don't
recognize the categories of moral and
immoral identity groups I think more in
terms of groups over which we can
exercise volition or not and the problem
with fastening on to identities like
race and gender are that we didn't
choose them and there's only so much
will we can exercise over them where's
one of the nice things about nation is
that we can exercise some volition over
at what a country is what our country is
would it stay
for and what it means to us and I'm more
interested in the aspects of identity
and of self that we can change and mold
because I think of self not as a static
thing I mean the whole idea of self that
we're now raised with is your already
pre-made and the project is to recognize
what you are already and that is not my
experience of being a person my
experience I don't want to go to New Age
on you but it's it's a continual act of
becoming of creation and I mean if
nothing else you continually have to
adapt to being another day older and
it's different so and that's a much more
dynamic idea of what it means to be a
human being and to focus instead on the
things that are never going to change
from the day you're born is it's like
locking yourself in a room yeah
Boston yeah
and then will come there and then will
come down again okay thank you can you
hear me okay yeah fascinating discussion
again thank you it seems to me more than
ever now listening to you this evening
listening to you you know running
through this this whole sort of panoply
we have no of negative ideologies it
seems to me that the most sort of
veralyn advocate for some of these
things is actually our own national
broadcaster it's the BBC
[Applause]
while you've you've answered you've
answered the first part of my question
which was to what extent do people in
the room agree with that I suppose just
other general level what interests me is
how have we got to a position where our
institutions seem so rudderless and that
we as the public seem so blase that they
can advocate ideology and pass it off as
facts with so little resistance yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yes and I would just add one color to
that which is the BBC like everybody
else is caught in the headlights of this
enormous e it's something I've
maintained so it's driven by a small
number of zealots with a larger number
of followers were persuaded that they're
doing the right thing but the BBC and
others are caught in the headlights on
this almost all institutions are I can't
stress it enough large corporations
governments commitments diversity all of
this stuff is all flooding across the
whole thing and that's why you get
spectacles like the last night of the
Proms this year and I mean this was
beyond parody the first piece is a piece
actually called woke commissioned from a
young talented black British composer
who writes a piece in The Guardian a
couple of days beforehand saying you
know I I have been able to draw on three
different cultures because in my
father's Egyptian my mother's kanae and
also this and and he said in three
cultures is better than one and well
that should mean your piece is three
times better than anyone elses and I
don't know if it is but but the point I
just knew the BBC was just absolutely
thrilled to be able to say we've got a
black compose commissioned the thing is
again it's it's understandable they get
there who wouldn't want if the guys
terrific and he was pretty good but we
know what's going on there just like
there's a soprano who sings at the end
of it I didn't if you saw this as
Canadian soprano who wore the colours of
the flag of bisexual ISM which I didn't
know that didn't had a flag and no
mountain I've ever seen it on and it's
not being flown before as far as I know
but it was flown by her and then at the
end of Rule Britannia she gets out the
LGBT rainbow flag and starts waving it
during elaborate Aniyah and just gay
just give us a break you know I don't
know anyone who thinks the world of
classical music is this sort of
unbelievably heterosexually dominated
you know just sort of purges all the
gays you know
and I give us a day off yeah
yeah thank you to ask you about
disenfranchisement come from a part of
the country that's traditionally more
left than right as a few people said
this even it's obviously this is
obviously a problem that
disproportionately affects left-wing
parties which leaves a whole lot of
people like me disenfranchised
completely disillusioned do you think
that enough people will end up like that
to cause a political shift so I sort of
electoral result like the private party
for instance or can it withstand as you
suggest in your book due to its Marxist
on the opinions and the second question
is what do people like means sensible
left-wing is do in the meantime what
this movement is doing to the left in a
broader sense is cooking its goose
they've run away with the Democratic
Party and you know we'll see what
happens with impeachment but if that
doesn't work Donald Trump could win this
election because the Democrats sold out
to its lunatic fringe and so it's having
a it's having a really deadly effect on
the left and one of the peculiar things
about the dynamics of the movement are
that their biggest enemies are not
right-wingers not real white
supremacists who are by the way are very
proud of being white supremacist that's
how you can tell it's classical liberals
they're the people that identity
politics that that crown'd go for people
like you and there is some kind of
psychological element at work that
people tend to be most hostile to to
ideal people who are ideologically most
proximate the the far left has no big
bone to pick with a bunch of racists or
you know real alt-right types it's no
fun you call them racist and it doesn't
hurt their feelings
whereas when you call classical liberals
racists they start to cry so that's
really fun and and that's the real the
real problem is on the left with in the
left and the hard left is at the
classical left's throat and the danger
is that you just take each other down
and what's left the right so politically
this is naff entirely endorse that
statement I just had one other thing
which I maybe you say um what can you do
answer that in a very broad sense if I
may you don't agree to lies and don't
agree to things that you think are
untrue it's incredibly demoralizing it's
incredibly demoralizing to an individual
and it is to a society when you have to
agree to things you know not to be true
and whatever it is in however small away
in our lives just don't go along with it
if you can help it and just stick to the
idea of having the right which we still
do have to say what we think is true
and we've got time very briefly number
six isn't ready what I'm very ready you
ready Douglas you suggested that the
self-employed may be lucky enough not to
have to worry about all of this so if I
may be permitted to use the phrase
speaking as a self-employed man sadly
it's not true so I find myself
increasingly having to fill in all kinds
of diversity questionnaires in order to
win-win work and I just wanted a piece
of advice from either of you
I recently filled out a questionnaire on
my gender which featured twelve twelve
possibilities plus none of the above
which certainly begged the question and
I just wondered is it a cop-out to
answer
I refuse to ask the question or prefer
not to answer when there isn't a box
marked this is all bollocks
[Applause]
I I think you can I think you can write
that in the only time I've ever had to
fill out such a form I break a
confidence in doing the coalition
government that the Conservatives tried
to persuade me to take up a public
appointment which I was very loathe to
do but they kept trying to push me I
won't go into the details it was rather
ugly affair but is the only time I've
ever filled out such a form and sexual
orientation that was quite a choice I
filled out that one accurately on all of
the others I said I'd rather not say
there was a rather not say box and I
thought the air of mystery yeah I figure
this prefer not to say box really
terrifies them hmm yeah mine isn't here
we said we'd go there there's a ban on
the tube they used to be announcement
ladies and gentlemen and made small
group of trans activists decided to get
this banned
similarly recently perhaps even more
ludora ludicrously all day always who is
a manufacturer of tampons has got rid of
the feminine symbol of them because
apparently men like me can also
menstruate so but the point is that the
reaction to this was overwhelmingly
negative and this was reported it was
all angry faces on metros Facebook page
and all the other newspapers were
reporting on people didn't like this and
so how do we get around this
I suppose this fallacy of numbers in a
sense that a small tiny group of people
can affect a change even though the vast
majority don't necessarily want it
I this definitely is in the area of what
Douglas was talking about is you just
cannot put up with lies and I mean
somehow we have to individually and
collectively refuse to go along with
this utter [ __ ]
I mean apparently you you can't say
pregnant woman anymore you have to say
pregnant person because men can get
pregnant too yeah I'm sorry but we've
just gone off into lala land and even
staying silent in the face of this stuff
it's to cooperate with lala land is to
live there whether you like it or not
and you know for us to have entered a
universe where we no longer there
believe there is such a thing as man and
woman and that that the whole idea of
sex is something we made up it's a
social construct and that your sex is in
your mind and it's assigned at birth as
if it were some kind of arbitrary eenie
meenie miney mo by bigoted maternity
ward yes oh we call it a boy last time
this is this is this is social insanity
and I don't think we have to cooperate
with it I don't we've got time maybe
from one or two persons then we need to
wrap up I think white liberal virtue
signaling and like while many people
being misled but it seems an underlying
level there is something a bit more
sinister like it does feel like there is
a deep disdain for like Western culture
Western civilization at large and I
wonder you know where the roots of that
are or if you agree that there's
something more sinister going on I'm not
sure I'd used the word sinister
destructive
[Music]
you know I I come from an American
liberal tradition and and there's this
strain of that tradition that has always
had contempt for the United States so
I'm very familiar with this and it seems
at first as if that's a form of
self-hatred so that you know
yeah that's maybe spiritually disturbed
but you know what it isn't self-hatred
they don't hate themselves they love
themselves they hate other people they
think they're better than other people
it's a kind of showing off and Americans
American liberals who have contempt for
the United States and professed to feel
better than the United States and
ashamed of the United States they're not
actually experiencing shame in fact a
lot of white liberal guilt is not really
guilt at all they don't feel bad they
feel proud of themselves do you know
what real shame feels like it's terrible
you don't want to leave the house shame
is crippling these people are are
delighted with themselves
and it's you know it's wearing a t-shirt
and O or perhaps instead of a designer
hair shirt right so one of the things
that bothers me about this kind of faux
self-hatred is is that it's it's
anything but what it pretends to be it's
lying it's hypocritical and it's it's
pretending to be looking into the West's
very soul and and worrying about all the
evil that has been conducted in in our
name but that's not really what's going
on it's just a big game of
one-upsmanship and quite frankly in the
way that it's being used
it is it it it is an insult to the real
often wicked history of places like the
United States and even the UK you're
being used we're going to have a final
question there now what I suggest is is
that with this one we both we said we'd
do a little bit of solutions we've got
about five minutes okay let's wrap our
solutions into this excellent final
question thank you
well first of all thank you for the talk
it's an honor to be here I grew up in a
country very different to Britain namely
Russia and I can tell you from my
personal experience that this problem
the very notion of identity politics is
not present in other societies it's
simply non-existent so other countries
other societies focus on scientific
research defense undermining Western
societies while we here in Britain keep
wasting time taking base a bit further
than we should we keep creating
motivations we keep limiting our own
freedoms and you argue that only some
horrible awful things can stop this my
question is if we keep doing this if we
keep creating more and more chaos in our
own society in the long run can Britain
and the West in general fall behind
other societies and can that lift
horrible things thank you
[Applause]
you didn't you didn't let us down oh I
do think that in some ways it's an
indulgence most of it aside from being
seriously destructive socially if
nothing else achieves nothing it sets
people against each other
it's very inward looking you know it is
interesting that even the modern form of
feminism which has attached itself to
this larger movement doesn't seem to
give a toss about real discrimination
against women in the Middle East and in
in parts of Africa
so it's myopic it's myopic and
self-involved and again it's this this
obsession with the small differences
with the proximate right so you don't
look out to other countries in other
places where if they do things
differently and they're really there are
real problems and I just I think this
kind of self absorption and I'm afraid
though I have been up to my eyeballs and
brexit since it started brexit just
having the same effect it's a it's a you
know you know nobody tells you but
actually in the big picture it doesn't
matter that much whether the UK is in
the EU or not we're both gonna be fine
at getting caught up into these what
ultimately end up being quite petty
disputes means that you're using all
that energy you know you know it you
know kind of running in place and you
don't achieve anything else and you you
abdicate other arenas including
international arenas Russia where you
might be effective I do think this is
the case I have a terrible vision that
the intersection lists will get
something like what they want everyone
will be in exactly the right lane will
have worked out exactly their position
in the hierarchy that day just in time
for China to take over and and it would
be a sort of cosmic joke that we as that
happened we were discussing gender
fluidity so so here's wrapping up here's
my here's why I want to help people to
get out of this as fast as possible I
think is a massive opportunity cost a
massive opportunity costs to our society
and to ourselves in this I spoke
yesterday for a very smart young guy at
Oxford who interviewed me for his
podcast and I said something about one
of the issues in this book and he said
well I'd have to look into the
literature on that and I said just sure
do but don't
do it too much I do it a bit but you
should be doing something else with your
time and this is what this is why I want
people to understand this is an
unwinnable game that they are being
invited to play because I think we need
to get on to doing something else what
would that else be well it's all sorts
of things but as a friend of mine was
speaking at Harvard the other day and he
told me he said the QA afterwards was
all about these issues these are the
luckiest these are the luckiest people
in the luckiest place in the luckiest
country in the luckiest generation ever
ever and they were asking about these
issues and he'd said to me said why why
are you doing this you should be trying
to work out how we live in underwater
cities you should be trying to work out
how we live on Mars you you want to work
out exactly where you are in the
grievance hierarchy just in time to work
out where you are in relation to your
neighbor and then the new neighbor you
have you think this is a useful thing to
do and here is the here is the problem
on this everywhere I go in the world now
whichever come came in I noticed this a
smart person with access to the Internet
can be at exactly the right and same
position anywhere in the world anywhere
in the world the farthest flung country
you like if they're smart and they've
got access to the internet they can get
exactly to the same place that you can
hear in London or Washington or
somewhere else and this is an
unparalleled opportunity in human
history and we're squandering it so my
invitation is let's get rid of this now
and let's move on to lives of meaning
and to doing meaningful things with our
time because if we look back at this
generation and we say we achieved it we
nixed the whole identity thing which
cannot happen that's not the greatest
achievement we're capable of and we're
capable of more
and we should get on to it
[Applause]
Thank You warden
we should with we are standing between
you and your drinks and so we shouldn't
do this any longer but perhaps we just
just say on behalf of line I myself
thank you to you it's just an enormous
pleasure for us to be able to come out
tonight to meet all of you and to have
the opportunity to engage in this
discussion and we don't take it at all
likely that you've given up this evening
to be with us than for us to be with you
so I just like to say thank you and have
a good journey home
[Applause]
[Music]